find the range and the mid-range of the
following sets of numbers so what the
range tells us is essentially how spread
apart these numbers are and the way that
you calculate is you just take the
difference between the largest of these
numbers and the smallest of these
numbers and so if we look at the largest
of these numbers i'll circle it in
magenta it looks like it is 94. 94 is
larger than every other number here so
that's the largest of the numbers and
from that we want to subtract the
smallest of the numbers and the smallest
of the numbers in our set right over
here is 65 so you want to subtract 65
from 94 and this is equal to let's see
if this was 95 minus 65 it would be 30
94 is one less than that so it is 29.
so the larger this number is that means
the more spread out the larger the
difference between the largest and the
smallest number the smaller this is
that means the tighter the range just to
use the word itself of the numbers
actually are so that's the range the
mid-range is one way of thinking to some
degree of kind of central tendency
so mid-range
mid-range and what you do with the
mid-range is you take the average of the
largest number and the smallest number
so here we took the difference that's
the range the mid-range would be the
average of these two numbers so it would
be 94
plus 65. i'm going to talk about our
average i'm talking about the arithmetic
mean
over two so this is going to be what 90
plus 60 is 150 150 plus
4 plus 5 is 159
159 divided by 2
is equal to 150 divided by 2 is 75
9 divided by 2 is 4 and a half so this
would be 79
79.5
so it's one kind of way of thinking
about the middle of these numbers
another way is obviously their
arithmetic mean where you actually take
the arithmetic mean of everything here
obviously you could also look at things
like the median and the mode so range
and mid-range